this episode is brought to you by the
ridge wallet
over there but hey that's just a
knock at the door huh hmm interesting
food
mom
open the server obey the server obey the
server
relate the server the server oh okay the
obey the server
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show where our motto is obey the
server
you know it's been a couple months since
we last checked in on the best youtuber
in all the universes your favorite
prematurely bald parental unit
dad for those of you who don't remember
the channel dad feels tells the tale of
captain anden ryls an
astronaut from the planet kepler-22b who
crash-landed onto earth was kidnapped
and ultimately brainwashed into
simulating the role of a stereotypical
suburban father via suspicious cans of
food
that'll feel good once he gets a nice
kiss on the cheek from his beautiful
wife
and since my first video exposing the
reality of that situation the drama over
at dad feels has evolved a lot
this thing has exploded you filled up
his subscription box which allowed him
to go
quantum and now youtubers like vsauce
and markiplier
are implicated robots are on the loose
the youtube server has gained a mind of
its own and it's dressing like scarlett
johansson
oh yeah and apparently i'm part of the
conspiracy too
dad saved matpat from the dark party
keep eating the food matthew yes we all
owe ourselves to dad
so what's the latest on the dad feels
drama and why should you be afraid of
what's coming next
we'll open wide and get ready to swallow
my big ol spoonful of truth food
shoved into your mouth repository today
your favorite friendly neighborhood
totally acting of his own accord
theorist is gonna fill you in on
everything you need to know
about dad 2.0
last episode i primarily focused on the
kidnapped astronaut anden and how he'd
been manipulated into playing the role
of dad along the way we uncovered secret
spectrogram codes and his hidden cries
for help as he struggled to escape his
brainwashing and imprisonment but
anden's story is far from where things
actually begin as we learn in the
series's act three finale
cheryl aka wife is the true mastermind
behind everything
the creation of the facility the birth
of the server the dad life program
all of it was her doing a massive and
complex plan
all rooted in one event the premature
death of her daughter lucia
cheryl like many an indie game
protagonist before her tragically loses
a child and becomes obsessed with trying
to bring her back to life but instead of
looking towards animatronics or sentient
soda cans for answers
she instead turns her attention to space
cheryl believes that her daughter died
and when someone dies
they're reborn into the next life
according to her research you could be
reborn on earth
planet nine or kepler-22b wait a minute
is that is that
michael stevens from vsauce nah must be
a michael bot anyway in order
to complete her research she needed a
source of funding and what's the best
way to earn money these days
being a youtube star fam cheryl kidnaps
and brainwashes the actor nathan barnett
to create the show
dad but when his mind was just too
strong
he's incredibly smart very subtle
writing there guys she needed someone
new to fill the role so the show could
go on
enter the crash-landed astronaut and in
who as luck would have it looks just
like nathan
to her benefit you look a lot like some
incredibly talented and famous actor on
this planet
the great mind of cheryl everyone
apparently overlooking the fact that one
of her underlings already resembled a
famous youtuber with over 17 million
subscribers
hey vsauce michael here but there was
still one piece of the puzzle missing
and it wasn't just missing in the story
but it was also missing on the channel
you see
dad feels was only subscribed to two
channels the hardware store true value
which provides great deals for anyone
who's looking to build the shed and the
second a small completely separate
account
titled youtube server with videos like
the completely innocuous corporate safe
title
welcome to youtube a video that would be
totally normal if it weren't for the
slightly weird messaging happening at
the end
thank you for your loyalty
the website is very happy cheryl created
the server to run dad's life since you
know running a channel is hard work and
probably best done by a cold heartless
ai
it's also probably why the men in black
that we see throughout the series
wearing a youtube logo on their chest
employees of the facility are called the
clients
they answer to the server for instance
anytime you play minecraft online you're
connecting to a minecraft server which
gives instructions back to the client
running on your computer similarly these
human clients take instructions from the
facility server to execute her wishes
on dad and of course the server is just
that your typical helpful and completely
subservient ai that controls everything
nothing could possibly go wrong in a
situation like that right
of course not the server starts to
self-upgrade and in a video titled
scarlet dawn it announces its new
identity
server upgrade complete welcome to
scarlet
scarlett is awake scarlett is the nerve
of the facility
for those of you who missed the anime
reference there in the 90s tv series
neon genesis evangelion
nerve is an organization that has
special authorization to put together
combat units to fight monsters
more importantly nerve is supposed to be
under the power of the un
but ultimately answers to no one only
enacting their own personal agenda
likewise scarlett appears to be on her
own mission unrestrained by any of her
creators cheryl is no longer in control
also while we're on the topic of sci-fi
references it seems like the name
scarlet
itself may just be a bit of a reference
to scarlett johansson
at the end of a four-hour dancing
livestream we see a spectrogram which
produces
concept art for the live-action version
of ghost in the shell where scarlett
johansson plays the lead role of the
major
note that this happened the same date as
the upgrade video that was uploaded to
the youtube server channel
also for what it's worth scarlett
johansson also played the role of a
female ai in the 2013 movie her where
she and the rest of the ai on the planet
eventually become too advanced for
humanity and end up leaving us all
behind so the references here
are pretty darn clear the dad feels
channel is now about a rogue ai that's
on the loose but why
what is scarlet's plot and how does it
tie back in with dad
how are dad and cheryl involved and why
do we need to now be on the lookout
up until this point i've been primarily
focused on captain anden's version of
dad but at the end of the act iii finale
in returns home both he and cheryl
presumably reunite with their loved ones
back on kepler-22b
leaving behind scarlett and the backup
army of hundreds of dad bots
all waiting their turn to boot up and
roam free without any sort of
supervision
hi welcome to tadpole the first is
identified as dadbot222
but he's not long for the world as
shortly after his debut he's
unceremoniously killed maybe dadbot
should get out and live more or less
in the following video appropriately
titled dad is dead we see his
replacement boot up dadbot69
dadbot69 is turned on nice
on his boot up screen we see something
that's a bit unusual a list of new
upgrades including stress
rebellion deception and mischievous
deadpod 69's
programming is contradicting and this
is our first clue as to what scarlett is
planning in a later video we learned
that
she is the one who's giving the dad bots
enhanced emotions
these models cannot even handle simple
emotions
all new emotions cube has given them has
led to countless errors
cute will ameliorate the entire network
she's trying to push the technology to
new limits
reach new heights she looks at cheryl's
goofy youtube plan as a complete waste
of the dad bot's potential
such a waste of bad bots cheryl's
programming makes a mockery of the
server's true power and let's be honest
scarlet's not wrong here i mean dad bots
are humanoid robots with complex thought
functionality and feelings
i mean you're lucky if a youtuber has
either of those things after scarlett
puts her plan into action dadbot69
malfunctions and we see a new upgraded
dad bot boot up in its place
this is our current main character in
the series there's also the newly
awakened rory we can tell that he's a
different bot because he wears a
different tie
but his role is still a bit unclear he
was last seen dragging a dead body down
a hallway
dead body that just so happened to be
wearing markiplier's cloak-branded
merchandise did rory kill mars
what do these bots want hi i'm dadbot
hi i'm mombot are scarlet and dad an
unstoppable team of murderous ai
not quite you see there's one final
secret rebellion that's going on in this
story
in season one it was about anden
fighting against the server once he
escaped the story became about the
server upgrading to scarlet to rebel
against cheryl but now it seems like the
dad bots are the ones rebelling against
scarlet
as the story continues it's becoming
clear that scarlett is spying on the dad
bots
constantly inside their mind reading
their thoughts scarlett
are you in my head yes but don't worry
i'm not spying on your thoughts uh
okay but dad is smarter than anyone is
giving him credit for in a fascinating
way to use the platform dad allows user
donations during live streams to shut
down his firewalls granting the comments
short-term access to his code in order
to unlock once restricted information
these moments are awesome because they
give us access to secret lore
or previews of lore that are going to
come later in the main series after
digging through
hours of dad live streams we learn that
the relationship between dad and scarlet
isn't what it appears to be
disobedience found emotion not fully
explored
disobedience is intriguing to dad might
need to hold this file somewhere for
further exploration
this is something that we can see
further in main uploads on the channel
i've deactivated the land to the
incubation room so scarlet will not hear
or lock our conversation
that's right all of the dad bots have
been working together in secret to
undermine scarlet's control
dadbot222 malfunctioning and getting
replaced by dadbot69 was no accident it
was intentionally orchestrated by the
dadbots from the start
dadbot222 agreed we'd have six nine
replace him to set in motion the
deterioration between cheryl and melvin
one thing's for certain though the
channel feels like it's been completely
flipped on its head
dad's season 1 was all about the role of
dad being played by a helpless man being
held against his will by sinister forces
this time it's the dads who seem to be
in the strongest position
though of course they have some fierce
competition after all scarlett's got
some newfound freedom and she's looking
to flex it i think it's time for
scarlett to plug into the facility
then i will learn everything this will
all be
mine but scarlett the problem with
thinking out loud is that people might
overhear you
because we haven't heard the last of
vsauce uh the the computer master
so scarlet's gonna try to find out in
the bottom of the facility
we may have just wrapped up a bunch of
season one plot threads with anden's
escape but it seems like there's plenty
this series has left to resolve
and the thing to remember is that your
viewership of this series matters as the
creator of the series nathan himself
said in a recent video with the channel
inside of mind there was more activity
on the dad channel with 5 000
subscribers than there was on my nathan
channel with almost 400 000
and then when i started like getting the
full videos uploaded my ad revenue was
going up and i had the nathan channel
and the dad channel now and it
literally saved my life and i didn't
have to move out of the out of the house
that's the power that you have by
finding a creator who's doing cool
interesting creative things you're able
to support him by watching
by streaming dad is a series that is
fueled by audience participation and i
encourage you to check it out and get
caught up if you haven't or if you've
fallen off
in the process you'll be paying it
forward to a creator who's out there
putting out some awesome
unique and innovative work but hey
speaking of dads roaming around the
overworld
father's day is coming up on june 20th
and nothing says
dad quite like the biggest wallet you've
ever seen in your life i'm talking about
a 20 year old piece of cracked leather
the width of the bible
i'm talking thick with three c's but
thanks to today's sponsor the ridge
wallet all of those back problems from
sitting on a bulging back pocket are a
thing of the past
the ridge wallet is a minimal stylish
front pocket wallet that's designed
first and foremost to be
thin strong and safe made of materials
like titanium carbon fiber and aluminum
the ridge wallet is built to last
plus it's made with rfid blocking
technology so you're protected from any
digital pickpockets you know i gotta be
honest with you about this one i was
skeptical
at first i've always used traditional
wallets so when the ridge contacted me
about sponsoring an episode
i didn't immediately say yes i gave them
a try since you know
i try and actively use the things that i
promote on these channels and i gotta
say
i am never going back within two days of
using this thing i was hooked i
literally went and bought one for my dad
steph's dad and a few of them for team
members it just
changes the wallet game into a lighter
more convenient package that looks cool
and feels
so much better than the old wallets that
i was using switching to the ridge
helped me to realize how much useless
garbage i was carrying around with me
daily
talking receipts from over a decade ago
punch cards from places i went to in
college
pokemon cards not even good ones just
like two zubats and a pidgey so with
father's day coming up help your dad
ditch the bulky dad wallet and get
something for the 21st century the ridge
is a perfect gift for him
and for you and to top it off they're
offering theorists 10
off and free shipping all you have to do
is go to ridge.com
film theory and use the code film theory
at checkout and with 30 different styles
of their signature wallet i know that
you're going to find the perfect one for
you that's
ridge.com film theory for your 10 off
and as always i'll see you
next week
[Music]